savage clone battles mind bending time
travel and more multiverses than you can
possibly imagine keep watching for more
from the best sci-fi movies of 2022
from the creative minds that brought us
free guy the atom project follows the
titular adam a time traveling pilot from
2050 who becomes stranded in 2022 while
pursuing an unauthorized mission there
he meets his 12 year old self and the
two atoms must work together to
accomplish older adam's objective get
back to 2018 to save his wife's life
same old same old right unless it works
more like a multiverse where each round
will create an alternative multiverse my
god we watch too many movies but time
travel has a way of making things
complicated especially since older adam
is fleeing a dystopian future with the
odds stacked against them big adam and
little adam decide their only solution
is to find the man who actually created
time travel itself their dearly departed
dad
the atom project makes maximum use of
ryan reynolds charisma giving him a part
that allows him to play excellently off
his younger self's vulnerabilities
notably newcomer walker scobel kills it
here plus there are time jets who
doesn't love time jets
after yang is a deeply moving
exploration of memory and grief in an
idyllic-looking future parents jake and
kyra have provided their adopted
daughter mika with an android sibling
named yang when yang stops functioning
jake promises mika he will have her
brother back to normal as soon as
possible but as they go through yang's
memory bank jake and kira make several
major discoveries about yang's past and
true depths of his soul what emerges is
breathtaking emotional and profound
proving filmmaker kogo nada is one of
the very best directors working today
writer director richard link later mixes
fact and fantasy in apollo 10 and a half
a space age childhood a kid growing up
in 1960s houston young stanley is fired
up by the apollo 11 mission
as he watches history unfold the real
details of the mission are interwoven
with his elaborate dream of being
recruited as an astronaut mostly because
he's small enough to fit in a lunar
module's tight quarters apollo 10 and a
half embraces nostalgia without
completely ignoring the upheaval in
america at this time
in this movie houston is just as
fascinating as setting as the moon
meanwhile rotoscoping a technology
rarely used these days captures
stanley's imagination in suitably vivid
fashion
in bell lonely teenager suzu leads
another life in the virtual world known
as you there she's a famous singer named
belle with charming freckles and flowing
pink hair after a concert is violently
ruined by a mysterious user known as the
dragon bell sets out to find him but she
soon discovers that they both have
tragedy in their real lives tragedy they
must overcome together bell features
stunning visuals and real emotional heft
brooded in all the trials and
tribulations of adolescence
brian and charles finds mild-mannered
welsh inventor brian creating a boxy
robot with the mannequin's head after a
thunderstorm brings the automaton to
life it dubs itself charles and develops
a keen interest in everything the world
has to offer
what was that okay
an unlikely friendship emerges as
charles grows more and more human at a
brisk 90 minutes brian and charles
offers the best of intentions and a
pleasantly genial story that will no
doubt leave a smile on your face
squishy body horror and nightmarish
advanced technology go hand in hand in
director david cronenberg's moody
meditation on art and humanity crimes of
the future cronenberg's sci-fi horror
hybrid revolves around the evolution of
the human body a government cover-up and
a straight-up medical nightmare
saltenser and his partner caprice have
turned the surgical removal of his
spontaneously growing new organs into
performance art which attracts the
attention of a group of radicals as you
may have guessed this film is awash in
gore
also notable is kristin stewart who
gives a particularly nervy off-balance
performance as timlin an administrator
at the national organ registry stewart's
weird energy is a perfect tonic in
cronenberg's morbid tale of surgery and
sexual attraction
sam raimi infuses the marvel cinematic
universe with his trademark horror
stylings and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness superhero sorcerer
steven strange must protect america
chavez a dimension-hopping teenager from
someone seeking to steal her powers
their flight across the multiverse takes
them to the very limits of existence
with strange grappling with his own
issues and confronting the darkest and
most disturbing versions of himself
meanwhile wanda maximoff emerges as the
emotional core of the film as she
struggles with the harrowing aftermath
of wandavision what results is a
thrilling blend of terror fantasy and
sci-fi one that proves the mcu still has
a lot of a heck to give
in the dystopian future of duel dying
people can arrange to have themselves
replaced by clones but what happens to
the clone if the original person doesn't
die so begins sarah's nightmare after
she survives a terminal illness sarah's
clone decides she wants to continue
living sarah's life by law only one
sarah can remain alive so the two must
duel to the death i can't have two of
you walking around forever
be ridiculous in duel writer director
riley stearns explores themes of
identity in a surprisingly comic fashion
despite the devastating nature of this
key dilemma simply put everything
everywhere all at once is one of the
best films of the year an endlessly
inventive and absurdist delight it stars
michelle yo as evelyn a middle-aged
laundromat owner whose irs audit becomes
a surreal adventure through the
multiverse as it turns out reality is
threatened by a fearsome being and only
evelyn can rise up to be the savior of
every dimension multiple viewings are a
must to catch every detail packed into
this wild heartfelt and colorful good
time king carr is a horror comedy sci-fi
oddity chock full of political
commentary the film stars luciano pedro
jr as uno a boy who can telepathically
communicate with cars he refurbishes an
old automobile the titular king car
providing it with the means to actually
speak while uno's power is exploited by
his uncle z king car has its own ideas
the bizarro absurdity of this
one-of-a-kind film spins out of control
at times but king car is definitely a
wild ride worth taking
at the beginning of light year audiences
are told up front that this is the film
that made toy story's andy into a buzz
lightyear fan
to infinity and beyond
the story sees the titular heroes
headstrong insistence on adventuring
solo strand a ship full of his fellow
space rangers on a hostile planet buzz
winds up working with this crew of
lovable misfits including his former
partner's granddaughter and an adorable
robotic cat named sox to make things
right but can they overcome zerg the
enigmatic villain who is dead set on
sending waves of robots after them
lightyear is a gorgeously animated
sci-fi adventure with plenty of comedy
and heart it's at its best when
spotlighting the crew's attempts to
figure out their strengths and when it
indulges in its absolutely incredible
hyperspace sequences whether you're
watching it on an imax screen or disney
plus this pixar tale is sure to
entertain and inspire
in last survivors troy and his son jake
live in a remote haven far from the
horrors of a post-apocalyptic landscape
though troy tells jake the world beyond
is a nightmarish waste that doesn't keep
jake from being fascinated by henrietta
a woman he meets while looking for
medicine last survivors distinguishes
itself from other post-apocalyptic films
by focusing on the character's inner
turmoil here their emotional journeys
take center stage rather than the
ravages of world war iii and the movie
has made all the better for it
an adaptation of the celebrated german
film run lola run luke lupita revolves
around a fallen track star named sabi
with her burgeoning athletic career
derailed by injury savvy starts off in a
dark place soon enough however she falls
in love with satya a charming criminal
after he leaves a bag of cash on a bus
savi must come up with the loot lest
satya be bumped off but there's a twist
savi is stuck in a time loop as the
story replays over and over again she
must use her knowledge to bring about
better outcomes more comedic than its
source material loop lupita is
nevertheless a thrilling trip through
alternate timelines where the slightest
change can have massive repercussions
neptune frost is a singular work of
afrofuturism it's a sci-fi musical with
an audacious vision that mesmerizes even
if at times the story seems elusive set
in burundi the film follows a colton
miner named matalusa and an intersex
runway named neptune whose coming
together gives birth to something
incredible at turns impressionistic and
poetic neptune frost features characters
with symbolic names such as memory and
psychology and it primarily concerns an
anti-colonialist hacker collective
waging techno war against an oppressive
police state when matalusa and neptune
meet it creates a jolt that powers the
collective's technological struggle
expect this movie's visuals and songs to
get stuck in your cerebral cortex for a
long long time what did you see
me
that was big
happy
horror auteur jordan peele strikes gold
yet again with nope a sci-fi horror film
about siblings emerald and o.j haywood
horse wranglers to the stars when a ufo
begins hovering above their ranch they
decide to catch it on tape but they're
not the only ones with plans for the
mysterious entity reporters
photographers and a sleazy former child
star all have their own designs nope
tackles society's exploitation of
tragedy humanity's relationship with
animals and the treatment of below the
line crew on film sets this makes for a
layered experience that will have you
questioning your own assumptions from
the very edge of your seat
strawberry mansion is a surreal sci-fi
rom-com adventure starring kentucker
oddly as james preble a government agent
who audits people's dreams that's right
in the future this movie imagines dreams
are taxed he soon discovers something
more sinister a foot as he investigates
bella an elderly artist and the sole
occupant of the titular home full of
bizarre logic oddball characters and
striking imagery strawberry mansion is a
splendid head trip guaranteed to do a
number on your imagination